elle est conseillère aux affaires
sociales analyser en temps d'un livre
printemps les grands-parents députée des
deux-sèvres intra muros est transformé
pour autant que la gauche
ségolène royal françois hollande se font
sur les bandes lnf il se retrouve sans
sable à 34 ans semble intenable pour
vous je restais la corrèze elle les deux
sèvres il n'y a pas de confusion elle
n'est pas élue partiellement en corrèze
et moi partiellement dans les deux
simples chacun chez soi
est ce que c'est votre mari qui vous a
incité à entrer en politique vous avez
suivi des chemins parallèles
non si on a suivi des chemins parallèles
bon c'est continue pendant nos études
donc on avait déjà un peu le même goût
pour la chose publique que si j'ose dire
et puis moi j'ai eu des responsabilités
importantes
après j'ai auprès du chef de l'état à la
présidence de la république et je crois
que tout naturellement et bon j'étais un
peu enthousiasmée aussi par ce métier
d'élu et puis l'occasion s'en est
présenté françois mitterrand unis à
inciter c'est comme cela que je suis
parti sur le terrain
auriez-vous était très très déçu c'est
s'il avait gagné pas vous non je pense
que l'inversé oui ça aurait été beaucoup
plus dur dans la mesure où lui travaille
depuis de longues années en corrèze
je pense que ça va être très dur s'ils
lui avaient été battus et moi et lui
outre la politique les problèmes communs
de leurs circonscriptions rurales il me
restera un sujet de conversation leurs
trois enfants de trois ans deux ans et
six mois
je crois que pour un député que sa femme
parce ce même métier au face à notre
métier c'est un problème que de
préserver son équilibre familial il ya
des manifestations on est à la
disposition des électeurs c'est le jeu
je crois qu'on peut pas se permettre de
vouloir se préserver trop alors qu'on a
fait le choix d'être allé au service du
plus grand nombre
donc il faut préserver notre vie de
famille c'est vrai mais nous sommes à la
disposition de nos électeurs
il faut essayer de trouver l'équilibré
et c'est peut-être plus facile lorsque
le conjoint que le même métier que les
façons les fins de semaine leurs
circonscriptions respectives
en revanche ils séjourneront en même
temps à paris du lundi au jeudi et ça
sert ont promis juré côte à côte dans
l'hémicycle